do you think it's a bad timing that Sue
Gray's appointment has also emerged now
and gives the conservatives a reason to
discredit what we've learned so far
well no because actually both reports
are very clear indeed they're based on
incontrovertible evidence it was very
clear that Boris Johnson broke the rules
that he was for example engaged in
Social and drinking events during those
periods when actually ordinary people in
our country they were following the
rules often at huge personal cost not
able to see their relatives for example
when they were incredibly unwell not
able to attend funerals you know I think
there's a really big question for Rishi
sunak now will he continue to prop up
the former disgrace prime minister Boris
Johnson with this huge legal defense
fund or will he be clear actually that
if Boris Johnson has been found to have
lied repeatedly to Parliament to have
misled Parliament repeatedly that
actually Boris Johnson's career should
be over big questions for Rishi sunak
around whether he has the strength to
take Boris Johnson on in that way
I mean you're talking about Boris
Johnson's political career potentially
being over uh do you think that he
should face sanctions uh following this
investigation
well I think above all he shouldn't be
supported effectively through government
money with the legal defense fund I
think that's completely unacceptable
ultimately Rishi sunak should not be
supporting Boris Johnson in that way and
I think there should be political
repercussions for Boris Johnson if he's
found to have repeatedly misled
Parliament the ability to impose that
kind of a sanction on Boris Johnson is
in the hands of Rishi sunak of course as
the leader of the conservative party and
I just hope that he has the backbone to
make sure that action is taken
is labor concerned that the appointment
of Sue gray as sickest Armor's chief of
staff is going to be a distraction and
will be used by the conservatives and
Boris Johnson loyalists to discredit
this investigation
we're quite the opposite Sue gray is a
person of enormous Integrity someone who
served in the Civil Service under
Ministers of a number of parties
actually someone who's always served
with that Integrity I'm really delighted
she's joining the labor team at that
point where we're readying ourselves for
government if the British public backs
us at the next general election where
we're determined to build a better
Britain and it's really great that Sue
gray will be on board with us doing that
yeah but you can understand why the
Optics aren't great are they you know it
gives loyalists to Boris Johnson a
reason to say that this report brought
by through gray was politically uh
motivated even just the impression of
impropriety can erode Trust
but what a road to trust was the
repeated rule breaking by Boris Johnson
and we didn't need you know as labor
said repeatedly at the time we didn't
actually need an investigation to be
clear that rules had been broken because
we could all see that in the photographs
that were published we could see it in
the police investigation that took place
which found that evidence of rule
breaking and which of course imposed a
fine and really there should not be one
rule for senior conservatives and a
different rule for everybody else but
that's what we saw taking place during
that covert period and the British
public has not forgotten it from the
conversations that I have with people up
and down the country
I mean civil servants have moved into
party positions before but can you think
of any other occasion where a senior
civil servant has been involved in such
a sensitive political investigation who
has then taken such a senior Post in the
opposition party
well we have seen those appointments as
you mentioned actually
this high profile following such as
politically sensitive investigations
such as party Gates surely there are
other talented senior civil servants who
could have been given this job
actually what's important to us as labor
as ever is that we see the same rules
and approaches being applied to this as
you would see with any other appointment
that's why the Civil Service procedures
on confidentiality will be followed it's
why the Civil Service Watchdog a Cobar
will need to look at this just as it
would with any other appointment and
it's quite right those procedures will
be followed they will be for Sue great
just as they would be for any other
senior civil servant
you say that the advisory committee on
business appointments um will oversee
this appointment you know as the
Watchdog but it's widely regarded to be
a fairly toothless uh Watchdog and of
course there are you know questions over
the fact that secure stoma is a personal
friend of Sue Gray
well actually I think it's really
important that labor is bringing in
people from a whole range of different
backgrounds into our team to make sure
that we will be ready for government but
I also think there's a big difference
here between Labor's approach and sadly
what has often been the conservatives
approach we want to be toughening rules
across government when we hopefully come
into government we said for example we
want to set up an independent integrity
and ethics commission that will ensure
that rules across the peace are tougher
for example around the ministerial code
and we will always follow rules when it
comes to our own activity in our
position and that's why as I just said
to you I'm sorry to repeat it but it is
important we're determined that those
Civil Service procedures when it comes
to confidentiality and also the
procedures of ecobar as you just
mentioned will be followed to make sure
that there is isn't a conflict of
interest